I am here with the incredible Zach bath
who has made a film honestly that when
you feel like you are at the brink of
true Brokenness and you don't know where
to move from there this film is so
relatable and has extraordinary answers
I just love this movie thank you now
someone who's also always been in your
life is your bestie Donald Faison and
you guys were just in a major Super Bowl
commercial with John Travolta do I'm are
we talking
because Ruffles are trending am I like a
throttle Donald and I both we're best
friends we both love musical theater so
when they came to us and they said do
you want to uh do uh Greece sing and
dance grease with Travolta we were like
what now and
um so it was it was magical I mean and
John was there was some choreography but
John was like no no no it should be this
and he was kind of like choreographing
me and Donald it was amazing and you're
like bucket list checkity check yeah
um I actually we got Donald to ask you a
few questions oh my gosh I'm nervous
[Applause]
when you and your bestie have like
private inside jokes you're like oh gosh
what the hell what the hell is going to
ask me well you're gonna find out
because this is fast ones with Faison oh
God
it's me Donald faisa all right Donald
what's your first question CB I hear
you're on Drew yes Drew what'd it do zbf
got some questions for you
I think the world wants to hear these
answers so I'm going to start with the
first one question number one
what do you think about while on the
toilet oh my God
only Donald would ask that of course and
the answer is clearly I play digital
backgammon on my phone
all right Donald question number two I
hope it's better than that
do you have a dating rule
oh if the person's like getting hammered
if like they're drinking like it's one
thing to have a few glasses I did I I
did that with you a few times well um
well that's the story for another
episode but um but when the person
um is like over drinking and you're like
whoa it's one thing to have a few drinks
but you're like she's like doing shots
yeah that's a red flag all right Donald
last question what's the last thing you
search for on your phone
um this is going to sound self-serving
but uh everyone was asking me in because
the movie's also coming out in the
United Kingdom they were like where is
it playing in in the UK and I was like I
have no idea so I was Google searching
where does a good person come out in
London and you and what is it uh there's
lots of movie theaters but I I posted a
link Tree on my insta story so if you're
in the London watching this
perfect well I mean that's you know the
film is coming out in theaters I Googled
that too yeah it's actually coming on
theater so please go I beg you please go
to the theater because we're lucky
enough to be having it come out in movie
theaters which is huge huge okay thank
you Donald Faison by the way for
your fun questions and a good person is
in theater now as we just said by the
way cannot love the poster more I have
to give MGM credit they really allowed
me to be collaborative down to the
poster so that's why we got a good post
well and it shows
from the poster to the film to Zach to
the great Florence Q Morgan Freeman
Molly Shannon everyone in it it's so
incredible a good person is in theaters
now
[Music]
foreign